bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui des nouvelles d'angeac
l'évolution à l'oeil nu
le plus ancien fossile connu un nouvel
homo et la mort de lucie on commence par
une nouvelle étude de la chimie
isotopique des hauts- de- annonce des
cavernes découvert en belgique
ces analyses montrent que la composition
chimique de ces eaux correspond à celle
d'un animal strictement végétarien et
pas omnivore comme peuvent l'être
beaucoup d'ours actuelle ainsi comme le
panda les ours des cavernes aurait pu
être inféodé à une source unique de
nourriture un manque de flexibilité qui
aurait largement contribué à leur
extinction
on reste du côté des plantes avec l'
annonce très contesté de la découverte
de fractures compressive sur le
squelette de l'australopithèque lucy qui
suggère qu'elle serait morte en tombant
d'une très grande hauteur peut être d'un
arbre le principal argument en faveur de
cette théorie l écrasement trait
caractéristique de la tête de l'humérus
l' os du bras qui semble s'être enfoncée
dans le corps de l'os
les auteurs de cette étude soutiennent
que ce type de fracture ne peut
s'obtenir que lorsque lors d'une chute
une personne consciente place ses bras
en avant pour se protéger si la fracture
s'était faite après la décomposition de
la chair alors les plus petits morceaux
d'os manquerait l'archéozoologue
français christophe rigaud souligne
toutefois d'importantes lacunes dans ce
raisonnement il déplore notamment que
les auteurs de cette hypothèse ne se
soit pas penché sur la microstructure de
l'os au niveau des fractures un point
capital puisque un os brisés alors qu'il
était encore frais aura une cassure plus
lisse qu'un os cassé une fois sec
il note aussi l'absence de comparaison
avec les cassures osseuse sur le reste
de la faune provenant du même gisement
effet ironiquement remarquer que si de
tels cas sur devez être identifié sur
des eaux d'éléphant alors selon la même
logique il faudrait en conclure que
aussi grimper aux arbres
un très bon point qu'il est néanmoins
important de souligner est que la copie
digitale en trois dimensions du
squelette de lucy qui a été utilisé pour
cette étude peut être téléchargée
gratuitement sur le site
il eût ci.org n'importe quelle
institution ayant accès à une imprimante
3d peut désormais imprimé son propre
squelette de lucy hominidés toujours
avec la description officielle de cette
mandibules d'un représentant du genre
homo découvert en 2013 en ethiopie la
gracilité de la mandibule et la forme
des molaires ne laisse aucun doute quant
à l'appartenance de ce fossile au genre
homo avec son âge estimé à 2,7 millions
d'années c'est
mandibules fait reculé de 400 mille ans
l'apparition des traits qui
caractérisent le genre humain ce qui
fait de cette potentielle nouvelle
espèce le plus ancien représentant de
notre ligne la description de plus de
matériels et d analyse phylogénétique
permettrait d'en savoir un peu plus
quant aux implications de cette
découverte sur l'évolution de nos
ancêtres
après le plus ancien représentant du
genre humain voici maintenant venir le
plus ancien fossile jamais découvert sur
terre il s'agit de stromatolithes des
empilements de calcaire de un à quatre
centimètres de haut formé par des tapis
bactérien il y a de cela 3 8 milliards
d'années
les analyses géochimiques soutiennent
l'origine biologique de ces formations
ces fossiles d'âge canonique fort recul
est de 220 millions d'années
la date du plus ancien fossile connu et
ce nouveau record risque d'être
quasiment imbattable en effet il
n'existe presque aucune roches
sédimentaires plus vieille que cet âge
il y à 3,8 milliards d'années la croûte
terrestre venait géologiquement parlant
à peine de se refroidir et et est encore
sujette à un pilonnage météoritique
intense appelé le bombardement tardif
ces fossiles montrent donc que ce que
nous appelons les conditions propices à
l'apparition de la vie il ya 4 milliards
d'années sont en fait bien différentes
de celles qui sont les plus favorables à
la vie aujourd'hui alors que vient
d'être découverte une exoplanète
potentiellement habitable près de notre
voisine proxima du centaure voilà qui
ravira les amateurs de vie
extraterrestre toujours au précambrien
nous terminons avec la classification du
site paléontologique de mystique unbound
au canada au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
le site est connu pour sa qualité de
préservation exceptionnelles et pour
être le plus ancien gisement de
l'étrange faune dédia car à la première
apparition indiscutable d'une vie non
microscopiques
il s'agit du premier site d'âge pré
cambria à recevoir ce statut prestigieux
et sa classification devrait
considérablement amélioré les efforts de
conservation du site et son aménagement
à des fins éducatives
espérons aussi qu'il inspirera la
classification d'autres gisements
fossilifères précambrien exceptionnel au
même titre la curiosité du jour c'est la
découverte à metz elle un gisement
allemand vieux de 48 millions d'années
du fossile d'un insecte dans l'estomac
d'un lézard lui-même dans l'estomac d'un
serpent tous les trois sont parfaitement
préservé jusqu'au brillant de la
carapace du malheureux
au delà de son aspect inhabituel et
impressionnant ce fossile qui n'est pas
sans rappeler le film inception
représente un instantané de l'histoire
de la vie de ces animaux
inutile de spéculer sur qui mangeait qui
tout est préservée directement dans la
roche ce fossile exceptionnel est clair
donc directement les paléontologues sur
les interactions écologique entre
espèces lors de cette période lointaine
pour la rubrique vintage de cette
émission je vous propose de revenir en
1958 dans l'illinois au célèbre gisement
de mazen creek incident connu pour avoir
livré quantité d'animaux fossiles en
tout genre et parfaitement préservé
cette année là il sera découvert une
créature fossiles étrange qui sera
baptisé tiny monstre hommes le monstre
de tully en l'honneur de son découvreur
francs si tu lis et du fait que comme un
monstre il semblait sortir de nulle part
avec son corps rondouillard et
apparemment mou et sa trompe filiforme
tully monstre homme ne ressemblait à
rien de connu
ce n'est pourtant pas un fossile si
ancien que ça le gisement de mazen creek
date de la fin du carbonifère soit
environ 307 à 310 millions d'années ce
qui en fait un site 200 millions
d'années plus jeunes que les schistes de
burgès un endroit où là on s'attendrait
vraiment à trouver des espèces
inclassable cela était d'ailleurs
d'autant plus frustrant qu'au fil des
années près de 1200 spécimens de tully
monstre hommes se sont accumulés avec
des états de préservation permettant de
voir jusqu'aux organes internes et
pourtant rien n'y a fait aucun indice ne
permettait de comprendre d'où venait le
tu dis monstre sommes et comment le
classer les paléontologues ont donc eu
pendant plus de 50 ans toutes les peines
du monde à lui trouver une place dans la
classification animal jusqu'en 2016 ou
dans un article paru dans la
prestigieuse revue nature's des
paléontologues se sont posé une question
toute bête et si toutes ces années nous
avions tenu le fossile dans le mauvais
sens les paléontologues avaient en effet
toujours considéré le monstre de tully
comme un animal à corps mou donc un
averti bray marin peut être un mollusque
ou un verre ainsi en regardant ses
organes internes il interprétait une
longue structure tubulaire noirâtre
parcourant certains des fossiles les
mieux préservés comme étant le tube
digestif maintenir le fossile avec le
tube digestif en eau qui changeait tout
leurs perspectives sur l'interprétation
du monstre de tully en fait il ne
s'agissait pas du tube digestif mais
d'une corde dorsale une sorte de proto
colonne vertébrale qui démonte
que tu lindstrom n'était pas un
mollusque mes approches parents des
poissons plus précisément tully monstre
homme aurait sa place dans la
classification animal aux côtés des
poissons sans mâchoires comme les
lamproies actuelle il possédait d'être
envieux pédonculé et sa trompe était en
fait fait à partir du cartilage de la
bouche formant un bras articulé terminée
par une passe et des dents acérées
il avait aussi des branchies tubulaire
et sans opercules comme les lamproies
actuelle il aura fallu un peu plus de 50
ans de questionnements pour qu'enfin un
regard neuf soit porté sur les fossiles
de tully monstre hommes et que
finalement le mystère de sa
classification soit résolu mais le
mystère a quand même du bon puisque tu
lis monstre homme lui doit sa renommée
est donc devenu depuis 1989
le fossile officielle de l'état de
l'illinois le coup de coeur de cette
émission c'est la possibilité de
visualiser la sélection naturelle et
l'évolution en temps réel à échelle
humaine
beaucoup pensent que c'est impossible
mais les deux exemples qui suivent
illustreront tout le contraire avis donc
aux professeurs de biologie commençons
par cette magnifique expérience montrant
l'évolution sur 11 jours de la
résistance à différents dosages d'un
antibiotique de la bactérie escherichia
coli de l'extérieur vers l'intérieur
sont disposés des doses de plus en plus
concentrée d'antibiotiques
chaque nouvel individu mutants devient
le fondateur d'une nouvelle colonie une
branche de l'évolution qui conquiert un
espace jusqu alors inhabitable pour
l'espèce c'est comme voir la phylogénie
se dessiner devant nos yeux
et pour ceux qui penseraient qu'il ne
s'agit que d'une petite adaptation
anecdotique de la micro évolution il
vous faudra bien réaliser que la
concentration d'antibiotiques au centre
est mille fois plus élevé que ce que les
bactéries introduite à l'origine ne
peuvent supporter ces bactéries ont
évolué jusqu'à résister à ce qui serait
pour nous comme plonger dans de la lave
en fusion pour le deuxième exemple nous
sortons du domaine du microscopique et
continuons avec un mammifère le diable
de tasmanie
voilà pas moins de 20 ans que ce
marsupial carnivore subi une épidémie de
la maladie la plus terrible qu'on puisse
imaginer un cancer contagieux les
pauvres diables atteints de cette
maladie développe des tumeurs sur et à
l'intérieur de la gueule puis meurent
généralement en six mois
étant donné la gravité de cette
infection et à quel point elle est
contagieuse les diables de tasmanie déjà
en sous nombre avant l'épidémie devrait
avoir disparu depuis longtemps et
pourtant voilà maintenant 20 ans que ça
dure et ils sont toujours là il
semblerait en effet que la maladie
laissés derrière son passage une poignée
d'animaux parmi les plus résistants ces
animaux ont survécu et se sont
reproduits et aujourd'hui les analyses
montrent que le génome de ces diables
comporte pas moins de cinq gènes mutants
codant pour le système immunitaire et la
résistance au cancer des études sont
encore nécessaires pour confirmer ces
résultats
mais il semble bien que la sélection
naturelle soit en train de faire son
oeuvre
la saison de fouilles vient de s'achever
sur le site fossilifère français
d'angeac-charente ce site
internationalement reconnu pour sa
richesse en dinosaures et son sauropode
géant a encore cette année livré une
belle moisson de trouvailles des
fouilleurs d'angeac ont accepté de nous
faire un petit bilan des nouveautés de
la saison 2016
on écoute jean coderre et laure osada
tous les deux fuyards à angeac et
doctorant au laboratoire de géologie de
lyon et au muséum d'histoire naturelle
de paris respectivement
oui ce qui est vraiment surprenant c
c'est la quantité d'eau ce qu'on y
trouve
c'est à dire que pour un mois pour un
néophyte qui arrivent là qui se demande
s'il va est ce que je vais vous
retrouver et des fossiles surtout mad et
des autres dinosaures bas dès la
première journée
au bout de quelques coups de truelle on
a déjà des des eaux
dorny tommy mother donc le dinosaure
autruches niveau à trouver par exemple
une bonne quarantaine de tibia droit
d'ornithologues mother ce qui veut dire
qu'on a au minimum une quarantaine
d'individus donc a priori un troupeau
dernier tome mozart voilà faut expliquer
comment ils sont arrivés là
oui donc on trouve des dents de de
crocodile de deux espèces connues polis
et nettoyés deux aux russes pour tous
les fouilleurs un tout ce que j'ai vu
moi-même quand on trouve une petite
danse c'est toujours un plaisir même si
c'est pas la pièce l'objet
paléontologique qui va révolutionner le
site d'angeac et la science en général
après donc on trouve également aidé des
restes de tortues en abondance beaucoup
de plaques
moi ya déjà deux ans deux ans maintenant
on a eu la chance de trouver une tortue
elle complète du clac et que la carapace
complète
voilà à côté de ça on trouve aussi
énormément dos du fameux grand sauropode
donc dont le
legrand fémur l'image un peu
emblématique donc ce grand sauropode
c'est la première année qui sont tombées
sur sur ce grand fémur d'un peu plus de
2 mètres 10 une fois une fois remontés
on n'a pas trouvé que ce grand fémur on
a trouvé pleins pleins d'autres
ossements fossiles appartenant à ce ce
grand dinosaure sauropode donc oui j'ai
eu la chance de tomber
c'était il ya deux ans deux ans ou trois
ans sur un espèce de mousse qui me
semblaient au début un gros galets dose
de sauropodes donc ce qu'on appelle
galets dos c'est juste un gros bout d'os
fossiles qui a été transportée et rouler
par le courant qui devient tout rond et
non identifiable par la suite mais
commençait à pleuvoir un peu donc
donc moi j'ai pris j'ai pris ce galet de
ces jeux les remonter au niveau des
tentes et on l'a on l'a frotter un peu
pour voir quand même ce que c'était d'un
peu plus près c'est avait accepté en
fait une belle griffes de sauropodes
donc plus exactement une la phalange
terminal d'un des doigts du grand
sauropode et elle faisait 35 cm de long
c'était la première
mais depuis on a retrouvé pas mal un peu
partout sur sur le site
maintenant on commence à en avoir une
une collection assez sympathique ce qui
était marrant c'était là le contexte de
la découverte puisque donc jeu comme
celle qui commençait un peu à pleuvoir à
peine on se rend compte que c'est une
griffe de sauropodes
et là on a on a pris un orage sur la
tête défend vraiment énorme et mazan
poste après une une vidéo donc sur son
blog avec dix tués la colère du grand
sauropode voilà après la découverte de
la griffe
le grand sauropode nous aurait envoyé
ces pluies antédiluvienne ça reste un
très bon souvenir
une découverte qui m'a fait le plus
plaisir c'est la découverte du plastron
de la tortue mon collègue renaud bourget
qui à côté de tomber sur une plaque à
plaques de tortue ils continuent à
fouiller au tour puis se rend compte
petit à petit quand fait cette blague de
tortue ben ali il y en a d'autres à côté
puis au final il fini de dégager ça et
là on se rend compte que il a trouvé la
carapace de la tortue au complet un peu
écrasée mais une est au complet et juste
à côté donc moi je vous dis un peu à
côté je tombe également sur un morceau
de tortue mais le plastron cette fois ci
est pareil je me rends compte qu'on
avance en dégageant que ce plastron et
complet donc ça et je pense que c'est
une des découvertes qui m'a fait le plus
ouais le plus le plus plaisir donc dont
je me souviendrai peut-être peut-être le
plus chaque année globalement on
retrouve un peu ou un peu les mêmes
fossiles l'ornitho mimose or bien sûr le
ce européen
le dinosaure le grand dinosaure
théropode carnivore donc sous la forme
uniquement sous la forme de deux grandes
dents tranchantes isoler les crocodiles
et tortues le stégosaure on avait trouvé
dès les premières années à quelques
vertèbres caudales les vertèbres de la
queue hélas cette année va essayer de
trouver les fouilleurs qui étaient là
ont commencé pour trouver beaucoup de
vertèbres de ce teaser de ce fameux
stégosaure notamment en fin de fin de
fouilles un jeune fouilleurs un nouveau
de cette année qui a eu la chance de
découvrir une superbe griffes de
stégosaure et à côté de ça des pistes
qui auraient été laissés par des
décodeurs en fait khimki qui aurait
marché l'aï laissé laisser cette piste
donc c'est vrai qu'à partir de là
c'était ouais c'était c'était assez
excitant avoir conservé une piste de
stégosaure vieille vieille de peu plus
de 130 maintenant peut-être un peu plus
130 millions d'années
ouais c c'est quand même c'est quand
même excitant si on a des sauropodes des
sauropodes des sténoses or qui march qui
se promène ici on a vraiment la preuve
que c'était pas non seulement un lieu
d'accomplissement de fossiles mais aussi
un lieu de vie du coût et de la
découverte par rapport aux autres années
de ses nombreux de ses nombreuses au
conte attribuerait du coup qu'on
attribue aux stégosaure donc les pas mal
de pas mal de vertèbres avec leur art
que noro encore en connexion plus cette
superbe cette superbe griffes de
stégosaure découverte sur la fin de
chantier
associé à cette ses possibles pistes
laissées par ces mêmes stégosaure où
elle était vraiment c'était l'année
l'année du stégosaure cette année j'ai
commencé par courrier un bénévole depuis
2010 donc le tout premier premier
chantier de fouilles paléontologiques
sur le site et donc depuis 2015-2016 jeu
je suis en tant que responsable de
l'étude de paléoécologie donc j'encadre
une quarantaine trentaine quarantaine
d'étudiants avec ronan allain gens
retournent sur le type pour l'avancée
scientifique de tête de la foule qui est
vraiment intéressant sur le site c'est
vraiment l'accumulation dans mythes
holly motors donc on a plus de la moitié
des ossements qui appartiennent à une
seule et fait donc une espèce de
dinosaure qu'on appelle aussi dinosaur
autruches alors on sait que c'est une
seule espèce parce que anatomiquement on
a pas de différence fondamentale
nos amis grecs sont très différents on a
plus de 50 individus donc de cette
espèce par contre de différentes tailles
donc elles seules différences
anatomiques on va trouver ça va être des
différences de proportions montagne on
peut comparer le profil d'âge donc les
classes d'âge dans l'économie moderne à
ce qu'on retrouve chez les autruches
actuelle donc les autres chaque tu elles
peuvent faire des troupeaux de 55
minutes on louret à angeac enregistré un
troupeau dans les deux mines d'or de
leur classe d'âge donc il ressemble
beaucoup à ce que au comportement des
autruches actuelle donc on a tout de
suite pensé à une mort en masse d'un
troupeau dormi comme inodore c'est à
dire qu'ils sont morts à quelques jours
d'intervalle au même moment et au même
endroit sur le sol chinois
vous voyez une autre interprétation
c'est que les autrement se sont
accumulés après la mort des individus
qui pour moi à des moments et des droits
différents et tous ont accumulé ensuite
par un courant d'eau pareillement
cependant moi j'ai relevé énormément de
13 de piétinement alors les traces de
questionnements c'était traces laissées
par les petits grains de sable sur les
os lorsqu'ils sont piétinés par des
animaux de grande taille
ça laisse des rayures un peu dans tous
les centres ou des patchs de prix
parallèle et donc mon interprétation
fait qu'on avait bien une mort en masse
d'un troupeau dorny pommeau d'or mais
qu' après leur mort
les squelettes ont été désarticulé et
des autres - été fragmentée et orienter
dans tous les sens parle un piétinement
intense en 2013 pendant les coupes
j'étais une expérience de piétinement où
j'ai demandé à quatre bénévoles de
marcher sur des hausses dans les
différents sédiments dans jackie et j'ai
trouvé exactement les mêmes traces que
celle sur les bords nicoli motors mais
cette année la grande découverte de
cette année c'est les empreintes de
stégosaure alors au delà des
informations que ça va apporter sur la
biologie des décodeurs et leurs
comportements grégaires et c'était là
parce qu'on m'avait petits des moyens
des grands bancs priori ce serait une
famille ta et a eu beaucoup réduit notre
hypothèse chamboulement des squelettes
dans little immo d'or du au piétinement
d'autres d'une langue tamoule estiment
qu'au delà pour en savoir plus sachez
que le site d'angeac peut être visitée
chaque année pendant la saison de
fouilles en juillet et ce gratuitement
renseignements auprès de la mairie
d'angeac charente ou à l'office du
tourisme d'angoulême
les fouilles sont aussi ouvertes aux
bénévoles mais attention les places sont
limitées
le contact est dans la description
l'info de dernière minute c'est cette
reconstitution surprise du dinosaure
psittacosaurus la plus réaliste jamais
faite puisque les paléontologues se sont
basés sur les traces de pigments de la
pop réservées dans la roche au tour du
fossile ainsi que sur des expériences
faites sur un modèle grandeur nature
afin de déterminer quelle est l
apparence la plus plausible de cet
animal ils en ont conclu que
psittacosaurus de vivre en forêt et que
ses couleurs devait lui servir de
camouflage
c'était paléo news merci de l'avoir
suivi un grand merci aux invités pour
leur participation
toutes les infos et les liens vers les
actifs sont dans la description
abonnez vous pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens à très bientôt